Bernie Sanders independent of Vermont
politically and legislatively where is
welfare reform in Congress right now
well I think debate is beginning in
earnest patsy mink is gonna bring
forward some very important legislation
i believe tomorrow and the fight is hot
and heavy my concern is that in the
process of welfare reform we begin to
look at the causes of poverty in America
that we make sure that we improve the
situation and not punish poor people in
children especially the children a
seventy percent of welfare recipients as
you know our children and then in fact
that we understand that a lot of the
debate about welfare reform is taking
place in a sense because of the economic
decline in our country and I hope that
we don't divide our people along class
lines but in fact we begin to stand
together and say how do we rebuild the
American economy how do we create new
jobs how do we raise the minimum wage
how do we stop the flight of capital
from the United States to Mexico to
China to third world countries where
people are being paid 12 15 cents an
hour as in the case of china by millions
of American workers are being thrown out
on the street I think you have to throw
all of that in the pot talk about how we
went from first in the world in terms of
the wages our workers received 20 years
ago to 12th place right now so I think
when we talk about welfare reform the
goal is to create an economy where all
of our people have decent paying jobs
now clearly it is not tolerable for
somebody who said oh gee I have nothing
else to do I want welfare I don't want
to work that's not acceptable that's got
to be eliminated but it is silly to be
talking about welfare reform it's absurd
unless we create jobs for people if
you're on welfare and there is no job
out there and we say hey we're throwing
you off welfare really what's gonna
happen and then when people say oh there
are plenty of jobs out there I say there
are nine million workers in America
today or unemployed real wages in my
state workers who are well educated
workers what trains were working decent
wages they've been thrown out on the
streets so what do you say about
somebody who dropped out of high school
and let me tell you something else what
people talk about welfare
let's get those people jobs the jobs
that those people are gonna get our your
jobs if you're making eight dollars an
hour nine dollars an hour now say you're
working in a school and somebody said
we're gonna put those welfare recipients
into the public sector sure they go
they'll take out the worker now is
making eight bucks an hour throw that
person out on the street take the person
who's on welfare today pay them for in a
quarter and put them in that job so what
I would suggest is that the issue of
welfare reform has got to be looked
within the context of the entire economy
representative patsy mink democratic
hawaii does the current system create
this cycle of poverty that congressman
Sanders was referring to hide your are
you talking about the welfare system
right now the welfare system doesn't
create poverty the welfare system exists
in America because we have poverty in
the country and because people are not
able to provide for themselves they
don't have jobs so I think that bernie
is correct the real problem in the
country is our economic system and it's
an ability to provide the jobs that
people need to sustain their families on
the era's well let me ask you on the
average how much does an average welfare
family receive I know it's depend
commercial but stay what's your range it
depends on what state you're from
because the amount of money is dependent
upon what the state contributes to it so
stated in the south they may get as
little as a hundred dollars a month
states that are generous like mine
perhaps about six hundred dollars a
month the average is somewhere around
three hundred dollars a month for a
family with two children so the support
by the government is not very large and
so but I think the issue is that people
are so concerned about their own
security about the future of this
country and so they're out there
reaching to try to find ways in which
things can be changed so that their
security can be better assured and so
they bash out that the poor they look at
welfare as a handout system of people
that are not worthy they try to find
other punitive ways to soak all correct
the system and what I'm trying
to do with my legislation is to say hey
wait a minute these people on welfare
are people like you and I they may be in
difficult circumstances right now by and
large what they need is help and support
they don't need to be thrown out onto
the streets and create another problem
for society so I'm hoping that we can
take a balanced look obviously there are
people in the welfare system that are
not going to be helped by any
legislation even the one that I have
fashioned but I believe that the
approach I'm taking will provide
substantial support and a quick remedy
there about five million adults on AFDC
and about nine million children we have
to be concerned about the children it's
not their fault that their families are
on welfare and we'll make sure that they
have support without a jeopardy to their
future so in a FTC aid to families with
dependent children yes good day from
Washington this is the latest in a
series of programs that we have been
doing looking at a variety of welfare
reform measure is now moving through
both the House and the Senate our phone
lines as always are open to 0 to 6 to 8
25 25 if you live here in the east and
for those of you out west 783 27 27 our
fax line is also open at 347 2111
earlier this month we talked to
Congressman Jim talent Republican of
Missouri is what he had to say about
welfare reform I think there's three
essential elements the first is ending
the enormous subsidy in the welfare
system which causes the creation of of
families in which there is no father
from the beginning other words it's it's
caused the out of wedlock birth rate in
the United States go to about thirty two
percent and that is because it presents
even even young teenagers with an option
of saying look if you're thinking about
having children even if you're not if
when you do if you have a child without
being married without working yourself
will present you a benefit package worth
on average about fourteen thousand
dollars a year it lures them in essence
into setting up a family which is then a
dead-end trap for them because at that
point of course they can't pursue a
career very profitable they have a child
they have to take up it's much more
difficult for them to form a normal
family at that point so that has to be
ended I think the second thing is to
make welfare a two-way street which
means a large workfare kind of component
to it my bill would impose a a
50-percent workfare requirement by the
end of 1996 and then I think also if
you're going to be serious about welfare
reform you should expect that the
welfare rolls would at least be held
constant as a result of your reform and
if that's the case then we should be
able to to fund welfare or welfare
programs without enormous new increases
so my bill imposes up the three and a
half percent spending cap on welfare
congressman Sanders that was about two
weeks ago with congressman talent what
do you think of that idea well I think
once again I believe I think most
members of Congress believe that if
people are able to work they should go
out and work if the kids are protected
and so forth I'd leave the problem with
what the representative forgot to
mention is that you have nine million
Americans today who are unemployed you
have millions more house are not on the
unemployment statistics because they
have given up looking for work and what
he forgot to tell us is what kind of new
jobs are being created the new jobs that
are being created are more often than
not part-time temporary work low wages
without benefits now if we're going to
be serious about talking about welfare
reform I think we must begin to talk
about a major jobs program and I and
other members of the Progressive Caucus
are working on a major jobs program
which would reinvest in America make
this country once again the greatest
nation on the world economically by
rebuilding our physical and human
infrastructure it is insane is the
representative forgot to talk about this
you say that you have millions of
workers who are unemployed will learn
earning inadequate wages and meanwhile a
physical infrastructure is falling apart
our educational system is falling apart
our childcare system is totally
inadequate our library system is totally
inadequate we can put millions
work is back to work rebuilding America
and then when the jobs are there you can
say to people if you provide child care
for people if we deal with our health
care crisis and say to a mother with two
kids you're not going to lose your
health care benefits but we're going to
continue your health care benefits and
then if you don't want to work let's
deal with that but the point that these
guys see these guys many of our
Republican friends they were the
architects of Reaganomics and they
transferred hundreds of billions of
dollars from the working people of this
country to the very rich and what
they're doing now is continuing that
process by dividing America and say to
the working people who are hurting very
very badly your enemy your opponent is
not the corporate America's who are
laying off millions of millions of
workers while the chief executive
offices you know he didn't forgot to
mention that the CEOs of American
corporations make a hundred and fifty
seven times more than the average work
they're taking our jobs to China where
the pain workers twelve cents an hour
unless we begin to get a handle on that
problem the whole discussion of welfare
reform is a fraud we want to get the
phone calls but in a minute or two
outline what your plan which is called
what jobs start yes what are the
elements of the planet how does it
differ sedate equip that we just saw
said as as long as we hold the line on
the numbers on welfare we're making
progress my bill will probably reduce
the numbers on welfare by at least a
half once it gets going and the whole
thesis is to look at the individuals who
are on welfare and make an assessment
there's a general myth out there that
everybody on welfare has never worked is
not educated we have looked at the
statistics and more than fifty percent
of the persons on welfare have a high
school diploma more than fifty percent
have worked and so what we're doing in
my legislation to take these people who
have the greatest success potential and
try to augment a training and job
counseling program so they can get on to
a job bernie is right we have to find
jobs first but for many individuals for
jobs that may be available now it's
going to require some degree of job
training and so we provide that fun
of course we have to have child care
there's no way in which we can have a
welfare reform program without child
care what we're also saying is that
let's take the welfare recipients who
have school-age children we don't have
to then worry about child care at the
onset the administration's proposals
take the youngest and so immediately
with infants we have to get the most
expensive child care programs in place
under my proposal we take the people
that have worked before who have a high
school education and who have children
in school we cut the cost of that
program immediately and I think that
we're targeted for success the program
is called jobs start America it's
unveiled tomorrow tomorrow in this
morning's Washington Post editorial on
welfare reform says quote congressional
liberals have weighed in to argue that
mr. Clinton may be going too far in
proposing a requirement that welfare
recipients go to work after two years on
welfare rolls the editorial goes on to
say that friends of the poor will do
their cause no good by defending a
welfare welfare system that is better at
maintaining people in poverty than it
moving them to the higher ground level
of self-reliance that's absolutely
correct because if you're all you're
doing is a minimum wage job or a
community service job which pays minimum
wage you are just maintaining the
poverty of that family what we're hoping
to do is to train individuals so that
they can move out of poverty get a
decent job so we have a maintenance idea
too that they don't go immediately off
of cash assistance let me just pick up
on Patsy's point and i agree with fancy
let's not just look at people on welfare
today because the people who were today
said all those welfare recipients be
careful tomorrow it might be you because
your employer may be moving to mexico or
moving to asia i think what we also have
to look at and we have legislation in
now which has close to 50 co-sponsors is
to raise the minimum wage people today
are making for that we have millions of
workers we're making four dollars and
twenty-five cents an hour the purchasing
power of the minimum wage has declined
significantly in the last 20 years that
means that the poor low-income poor
working poor in america a much poorer
than they were before what we have got
to do is
make policy in this country that anybody
who works for a living is entitled to be
above poverty now once again let's talk
about what's going on in the economy
there was a study that came out from the
census Department not so long ago and
what they said is that half of the young
workers in America the new jobs that are
being created are paying less than 13
thousand dollars a year how do you bring
up a family on less than 13 thousand
dollars a year for the first time in the
modern history of the United States the
younger generation is going to be poorer
than the older generation now our
conservative friends aren't talking
about those issues they aren't talking
about attack system in America which
raises taxes on working people
middle-income people but has for the
last 15 years lower taxes on the wealthy
starving cities and towns for the
resources that they need very quickly
should there be a two-year limit though
for welfare yourself absolutely not you
just simply don't say within a country
without a context throw people into the
streets but we don't care about your
children no you can't do that thanks for
waiting Duluth Minnesota good morning
I'm an avid fan watcher I'm just
Restless morning however my comments are
directed mainly at the gentleman from
from Vermont and the lady from Honolulu
as has been happening frequently whether
we're discussing health care are now
this reform the focus is continually on
economics I think the change of
gentleman from Vermont is mixing up many
things people who are on welfare and who
are underserved underemployed have many
human issues that need to be resolved
first they can't many of them even get
to work on time well I think what we
need to do is begin to focus on
rebuilding the family and trying to help
these people and employers to develop
programs that would allow these people
to be mentored and and to do such things
as get to work on time like you and I do
in the 60s there were many psychological
studies done at Yale I think we better
pull those back again and before this
gentleman tells a Republican gentleman
that has forgotten a lot of things I
think this gentleman better go back and
end
or ivory look at his own views in light
of whether or not we have minimum wages
or maximum wages or what I think the
first issue is people and families and
their values and what they thought thank
you thank you very much congressman
Sanders well the woman suggests that
perhaps as I understood her question
that I'm focusing on economics too much
I think that not to understand that the
breakup of the family in America many
many families is directly resulted with
consistent with with the decline of our
economic well-being is Israel what you
have right now is a significant growth
in poverty in America in many minority
communities in America you're talking
about thirty forty fifty percent
unemployment and I think while everybody
is distressed about children being born
out of wedlock and the breakup of
families not to see that within an
economic context i think is mistaken who
is co-sponsoring your plan well we're
out now distributing the bill and the
drafts and we hope to have a significant
number earlier on when we first got
glimpse of the president's proposal we
circulated Bernie and I a letter to the
President and obtained about eighty nine
or so signatures on that letter asking
emerging him not to put in a two year
limit basically so I assume that
interest still remains among that group
and I hope to enlist it there
co-sponsorship for directed you are a
co-sponsor of the bill I will be a
co-sponsor Johnson City Tennessee good
morning hello this little personal story
for the two representatives that feel
that situations may be dealt with
similar to previous caller have a
personal example of feller that I was
trying to help out he with a high school
dropout he just couldn't hold a job I
let him stay with me for a month so the
eventually
to jail for breaking and entering the
the injustice though it was really that
he was collecting his welfare check
while he was in jail and it's I mean
this is someone that I knew I knew that
this was happening I called dad I called
the office that was responsible for this
the governmental office may said you
know we have no way of checking up on
these sorts of things how long was he in
jail taller approximately two months
okay I've been up after that um he went
to jail for auto theft and fraud oh you
know he's still collecting the checks
while he's in prison sir thanks for
calling well that's absolutely not right
and it's a matter of insisting on proper
and adequate administration of the laws
i don't think you condemn all the rest
of those who may be on welfare because a
system has been incapable of enforcing
the rules there's no reason why someone
in jail should receive welfare checks if
you've just joined us we were talking
about welfare reform the president's
plan is expected to be out early next
month it's been delayed on several
occasions is the administration also
works on health care reform last week at
a news conference Wolf Blitzer talked to
the president about the issue reform
which has been delayed you know
repeatedly over these months so many of
your colleagues are so many Democrats in
Congress a health care reform should
have the priority now that if you do
going forward with a welfare reform
package to in terms of finance in it
that would money the waters make it more
difficult to get health care reform
since welfare reform is dependent as you
often say on welfare on health care
reform why not simply delay welfare
reform a little bit longer so you get
health health care first well
at first let me say Congress just as it
did last year when we had the most
productive first year of a presidency in
40 years I guess Congress has a lot to
do they've already passed major
education reforms school that work gulfs
a thousand Head Start expansion they
still have to deal with lobby reform
campaign finance reform most importantly
to me the crime bill as well as a health
care issue but as you have seen with
with health care are with welfare reform
introducing a piece of legislation
starts a process that does not finish in
a week or a month and i think the
outlines of the principles that i have
embraced on welfare reform are very well
known indeed my my own views on this are
not markedly different from the bill
introduced by mr. mccurdy and others
except for the way that i would propose
to pay for it and so I think that
putting out in the late spring we're a
little later than I thought we'd be I
thought we'd have this bill out around
the first of may but putting out the
bill so that the Congress can can see it
and see what I think ought to be done
and how I would propose to pay for it
and so the Democrats and Republicans
alike can't evaluated there's an
appropriate thing to do it might catch
fire the whole thing might catch fire we
might have a bipartisan consensus to
move the bill in a hurry and get it this
year I wouldn't write that off but I
don't see that that will undermine
health care it is however the flip side
is true until you find a way to provide
health coverage for all workers you will
never have full welfare reform because
you're going to have people staying on
welfare because that's all the way their
kids can get health care and you're
going to have the anomaly of people
getting off welfare taking low-wage jobs
giving up their health coverage so they
can earn taxes to pay for the health
care of the people who stayed on welfare
so it is but that is the more important
issue for the long run but I don't
believe that that my introducing my plan
will undermine our ability to achieve
health care reform this year congressman
Sanders that was last week at news
conference in the east room
it is their bipartisan support for
welfare reform on Capitol Hill well I
think I'm not a democrat or republican
so you might want to make that tripod is
that I'm an independent I think that
there is widespread acknowledgment that
the present system is not working nobody
wants to see people become dependent
upon a welfare system generation after
generation uh no one wants to see people
who are capable of going out and getting
a job not taking the job but having said
that the analysis of what the problem is
in the solutions I'm afraid are very
widespread from Palmdale California good
morning good morning I'm beginning to
think that the only time the Republicans
make any sense is when their lips are
not moving I'm really you know I'm
sitting here where does this man that
spoke two weeks ago get off fan that
they get a package worse 14,000 to an
unwed mother with a child it's ludicrous
it's absolutely ludicrous I have a
neighbor that's on welfare she gets one
hundred and thirty-five dollars a month
per child when it's all broken down the
poor girl can't live now I want to say
this but they're talking about getting
the people off welfare under jobs jobs
for what four dollars an hour that man
Sanders is absolutely right I don't know
what this woman thought job start
America's all about but I won't say this
a refugee with refugee status in the
United States has more wealth and
prosperity than a united states citizen
these people out there and us America
that that woman calling in and said that
welfare people can get to work on time
does she know what she's talking about
there are good decent people that are
left with children husbands are walking
off and leaving them these men are
marrying again starting up other
families which they should not be
allowed to do when they can take care of
the family they have I'm gonna jump in
thanks for making those points and we'll
get some reaction thanks for calling in
Congress wanna tell me an agreement with
what she said
I mean I think that many people operate
on myths that the people on welfare are
different than the rest of us they don't
have the same concerns and aspirations
for their family and I think that's
terribly wrong and so what I'm hoping to
be able to create is a different view of
the welfare recipient and to provide a
program of hope where those that are
most likely to succeed and the
statistics are there we believe that at
least half if we could augment the whole
program with job training counseling and
so forth that we could get them on into
a job and to stay there permanently the
phenomenon in welfare is it because we
don't have a support system they go off
they work for a few months and then
something happens there they're back
into the system so they come in and out
I think that a positive program which
concentrates on the total issue of
preparing them for a permanent job and
getting them into a job that pays a
decent wage is the most important
element of this whole effort when we
were watching the president at his news
conference from last week you said that
he is going to unveil his welfare plan
net in early June when Congress is out
of session why would he do it then and
not when you're in session well I think
that's typical of most administration's
I don't think that it's unique to the
President and they like to have a open
opportunity to present their side
without it immediately hitting a lot of
objections from people in the Washington
scene so this is what I expect that it
will be done next week when the Congress
is in recess and then we'll come back
and we'll have to deal with it but I
think most of us know what his plan
entails it's got the two-year cut off
which most of us object to what happens
after two years I mean it to me it's
just an empty situation if you can't get
a job you you're off of welfare who's
going to provide the job Patsy raises I
think the right question about the
children
and what we have to ask ourselves is is
it acceptable in America today that we
have x double the highest rate of
childhood poverty in the industrialized
world now we really want to go to war
against the children of America
twenty-two percent of the kids in
America today a living in poverty the
estimate is we have five million
children who are hungry today are they
really the enemies and I have to tell
you I don't know if Patsy agrees with me
or not but I I think that a lot of this
discussion about going hard against and
taking on the victims hungry children
there are enemies is a deflection of
really where we should be focusing while
we speak right now corporations are
disinvesting from American cities from
rural areas they're taking our jobs to
China 12 cents an hour they're taking
our jobs all over the third world maybe
instead of dividing up america between
welfare recipients and the working poor
and the working people and the middle
class maybe we should all come together
and ask ourselves a hard question how do
we reverse the decline in our economy so
that we begin to have an economy which
pays working people decent wages and we
have a full-employment economy I don't
see our friends talking about that issue
terribly much how do we say to corporate
America don't throw millions of workers
out on the street because of new
technology use that technology to
increase wealth in America not to take
for working people out onto the street
once we begin to do that I'm sure the
issue is the same in Hawaii in my state
of Vermont we have a very strong work
ethic people want to work and when the
jobs are there people go out and they
work and therefore it seems to me the
job of the United States Congress the
job of the president the job of
Corporate America is to say how do we
create an economy where the jobs are
there for people that's really what the
issue is let's get this call from Miami
good morning I've never heard a better /
old town meeting speech in my life but I
don't know what in blazes I have a
direct this to representative make I
think she earned it over the years
really and it's not a liberal question I
have but it pertains to a study which i
think is related to this issue
regarding judge sessions study it that
it may not seem immediately related I
don't know it has to do with something
that that hasn't been brought up
recently it's it's something that you
may think is not related but I'm sure
you walk on it when I'm through if
you'll allow me to ask the question I
don't know what in blazes my generation
of the 50s can't figure out the the the
welfare problem and and the reason why
so many people are signing this living
will if you'll allow me I'll get to the
point yeah we're short on time I know
this is probably a lot of people have
put up with this what's the talk shows
have to offer us but I don't think this
is ever really this maybes too
intelligent for talk shows I think our
welfare system is more crumbling not not
because of the obvious attempts of good
men to do something but an invidious
sort of thing like you get a leader like
Jacqueline Bouvier Kennedy who signs a
living will and poor people out there
actually are forced to sign a living
will to be 0 so their families so they
die and there's no rly ghal liability on
their health care providers or the
trauma network to provide them with the
health care so they're practically
forced to sign a living will and die to
support their families well that that's
tragic if that is happening in our
medical system and certainly it links up
the importance of passing the health
care bill they're all linked together
many people are not able to get off of
welfare because of their fear if they
took a job that was not covered by
health care that they would be forced
into those circumstances we hear it
every day and so there's no question in
my mind that health care must be passed
first and then we could move into our
welfare reform you just pick up on the
point that's a little bit tangential to
what we're talking about today but the
evidence is overwhelming and the studies
are quite clear that working people and
poor people live longer than wealthy
people there's no question about that if
you're poor if you're working class
person in this country you will die
younger than the people who have the
money and one of the reasons is is that
we have 37 million Americans without any
health insurance and tens of millions
more or only partially injured who have
large the duxelles people can't even
afford to go to the doctor anymore so
they're feeling sick they say well it'll
get better tomorrow you know they wait
three or four months they walk into the
doctor's office and the doctor said I
can't help you know we have to go for a
major surgery so to the degree in terms
of health care yeah working people poor
people are suffering terribly because we
are one of two nations in the
industrialized world that do not have a
national health care system guaranteeing
health care to all people by my count
according to congressional quarterly
there are three House bills and three
Senate bills moving through Congress on
welfare reform does that sound right to
you Ronnie three that have been
introduced as of tomorrow there'll be
four in the house Chesapeake Virginia
excuse me Chesapeake Virginia your next
good morning and thank you very much for
receiving my call I am very much an
agreement buffet mr. Saunders a cat
disagree with the lady from Hawaii i
guess but i am terrible to distress that
they sound over calls that are coming in
with respect to welfare it is clear to
me that the folk who are calling in or
have called in this morning have no
concept whatsoever or what it is like to
be on welfare i am an individual who
grew up on a farm left the farm without
one Brown penny I chose to become
professors rather than a prostitute I am
present presently retired and I'm
retired on a reasonably comfortable
income but there are so many people
particularly in today's society who have
never ever been able to obtain a job our
men have grown from boys to men manhood
and never have known what it is like to
hold a job so how can you learn the
attitudes the work attitudes if you
never had a job thanks thanks very much
for phoning in
humming I have no disagreement with that
that's our whole purpose and trying to
emphasize what's wrong with our economy
here the importance of job job training
and allowing people the opportunity to
have the dignity of supporting your own
family mr. Sam I think woman's statement
was was profound and very moving and
she's absolutely correct but I want to
reiterate a point because it's not made
very often enough it is very easy to
come down heavy on poor people it is
very easy you know why poor people have
no power poor people don't vote poor
people are a good target for demagoguery
and yet I find it so very interesting
that the same politicians of the courage
to beat up on the poor they have nothing
to say about the heads of the major
corporations in America which are
disinvesting which are throwing our own
people out on the street moving to the
third world how can we have nothing to
say about those people when you talk
about the increase of poverty and
joblessness and welfare what about
somebody who has a profitable company
where they're paying workers in my state
/ month okay fifteen dollars an hour in
a factory in the southern part of the
state Johnson Controls is the name of
the company we have worked as they're
earning decent wages good Union good
benefits the company decides to move to
Mexico throwing those workers out on the
streets happening all over America I
don't know what's going to happen to
those workers inventing different month
maybe some of them will end up on
welfare I don't know but we have nothing
to say about the large corporations or
making those decisions in order to make
the rich richer somehow the radio talk
show hosts have nothing to say about
that the leaders of our political
parties have nothing to say about that
why are those people contribute heavily
to political campaigns those people
attend a thousand-dollar up late dinners
but poor people no problem you can say
anything you want any outrageous thing
you want what people do not contribute
to packs they don't go to the
thousand-dollar or play tennis so I
think once again I want to make this
point because this is to me the most
important point if you're working right
now and you're working hard you're
working long hours and you're hurting
you too can't afford health care you
can't afford to send your kid in college
don't let the wealthy people in this
country
force you to get angry at the people
below you let's begin to get together
and focus on the real causes of the
problems and ask ourselves for example
while the rich why the richest 1% of the
population own more wealth than the
bottom ninety percent we don't talk
about that issue too much while the
chief executive officers who throw
people out on the street earning
millions and millions of dollars in
salary once again let's all come
together as a nation let's not divided
by class by race by religion let's come
together and create an economy which
provides hope for all of our people it's
the middle of the night in Hawaii that's
where our next call is from ia ha Hawaii
good morning to you thank you for
letting me call in um I have a question
here should the people these poor people
with representative from Vermont was
just talking expect some subrogation of
their rights or are they entitled to
maybe additional rights two examples i
can think of here in hawaii those on the
welfare rolls are receiving free
automobile insurance another example is
presidents clinton's statement that he
wanted to find a legal way to conduct
weapons sweeps and weapon confiscations
in the public projects in chicago
congressman i think that in a free
nation a great nation like America all
people should have the same rights in
the same opportunities thank God 40
years ago 50 years ago we entered the
apartheid against black people which
existed in the south and we said they're
all people have a right to go to the
same schools travel on the same buses so
to his greater degree as possible we've
got to say to all the people especially
our children what a stigma it is what a
stigma it is throughout America today
for the kids for the poor kids to be
internally feeling that they are not
equal to they're not as smart they don't
have the same opportunity as operating
come kids so my view is everything being
weak well all people should have equal
rights I'm a Pats equal know more about
a wide law but I suspect the auto
insurance thing means if people if you
if you say to everybody that they must
have auto insurance that's the law of
the state then you say to you you have
to have a job well how do you get to
your work unless you have automobile
insurance and
probably what was going on there yeah
it's the same problem as in the
healthcare poor people can't afford
health insurance or their employers
don't provide it so they end up in the
emergency room the emergency room costs
are much higher than ordinary healthcare
all of us pay for it same thing happens
in automobile insurance the uninsured
motorist cost is borne by everybody that
buys automobile insurance policies for
themselves so some years ago what
happened in Hawaii was a no-fault
insurance program which said that the
government would pay for those who had
no income or unemployed so that the
uninsured part of that program didn't
have to be transferred to the people who
bought their own insurance policies so I
think that's a not a situation where the
poor are being put upon but that they're
being given the same advantages that
everybody ought to have it was it with
respect to the sweep and the housing
projects I think that that is simply a
tragic situation where you have housing
projects with such a heavy incidence of
crime where the assault weapon is a
handgun and I think that it is a matter
of legitimate concern by police
authorities to go in and try to do
something about that public safety issue
both our guests have been in the US
House of Representatives for the past
two and a half years congresswoman mink
is no stranger to the house you were
first elected in 1977 though and left in
90 sec 1965 left in 1977 right and is a
native of Hawaii congressman Sanders is
originally from brooklyn new york
graduate of the university of chicago
and is the only independent in the US
House of Representative elections
charleston south carolina thanks for
waiting yes good morning mr. Sanders um
I am an independent and you just give me
all kinds of faith that you know we can
prevail but um I was a case worker I was
a social worker for four and a half
years and at the welfare department and
I worked two and a half years under
Jimmy Carr
and I work two years under Ronald Reagan
now in 1981 in January one of the first
things that happened that Reagan did was
he changed the criteria for a lady that
gets day care if they worked 32 hours a
week at minimum wage they made too much
money for daycare now another that then
within 10 days he said that if you were
19 years of age and a student you can no
longer qualify for food stamps so we
have the EOG grants and we had Pell
grants and we had tools at that time to
help women you know get off of welfare
so now this week this needs to be
reinstated because these ladies were
trying they were going to school they
were working they had daycare they got
some food stamps they had a little bit
of educational help and this all helped
us to you know get these ladies off of
welfare that all changed under Reagan
and these ladies quit school quit work
and everything in droves because he just
Mets the rug right out from under them
and we need to go back to you know
giving welfare workers social workers
some tools to help these women because
they do not want to live on welfare but
they're not stupid and when it comes to
supporting their family you give them no
choice for any advancement they all
right I've got to stop you there because
we are short on time thanks for calling
that's exactly the point that we're
making with my job start America bill
we're saying that at least half of the
people who are on welfare are there
because of very difficult circumstances
someone in the family lost a job or
whatever but these are people that have
tremendous potential we ought to
concentrate on it because it's going to
be a short amount of support that they
need and continue their housing
assistance continue their educational
assistance continue their child care
don't put
barriers along the way to their re-entry
into the economy it's really a very very
simple effort and I think that if people
would look at this bill they'll see that
it has enormous potential of eliminating
i would say about half of the people on
welfare support today immediately a fax
from Scranton Pennsylvania Ron Perry
writes congressman Sanders why do people
have children if they can't support
themselves are your bad choices my
responsibility but we all have children
I have fortune uh I don't know how many
children do have a child I think once
again in America let's look at ourselves
as one family at one people and not go
to war against the poor this last caller
called up and made the point that many
of the victims of what's happened in
this country in the last 15 years or not
only children but they are poor women as
well we are a great nation we are a
dignified nation we should not be
beating up on the most vulnerable people
in our society we have time I think for
one more call Oklahoma City Oklahoma is
still with us oh yes go ahead please I
have ten young ladies working for me all
of them are going to college minimum
wage they're not making a lot of money
but they survived and they're not on
welfare and they resent welfare they
resent the government paying of their
paychecks if they'd have enough money to
do their job and go to school if they
weren't paying for all the people on
welfare well let me just take a shot at
that welfare is just to be set the facts
straight one percent of our national
budget it's about 17 billion dollars we
should tell those young women that we're
spending a hundred billion dollars a
year defending Western Europe in Asia
against a non-existent enemy we should
tell those women that their taxes are
much too high because we are lower taxes
on the upper income people and I think
the mythology that it is welfare which
is bleeding this country is wrong on the
Reagan on the bush taxes went down for
the wealthy they went up
middle income and working people I think
we've got a reverse that you get the
last one thank you I think that it's a
shame that we have to sort of pit people
who are working at minimum wage against
those who have nothing I think we are a
big and compassionate country we ought
to be dealing with some of these things
in terms of their root causes many of
these women on welfare want to be able
to support their families they want to
be self-sufficient they just need a
little help and that's the help that
we're hoping that we can provide get
them into a work situation hopefully
they can do better than minimum wage but
if not at least a minimum wage job it's
costing the government now to maintain
them on welfare surely you can't reset
the fact that we're going to provide
some assistance to them so that they
could get out there hold a job support
their families and live in dignity
that's all we're trying to do
representative patsy mink Democrat from
Hawaii's second District her job start
plan will be unveiled tomorrow here in
Washington thanks for joining us and
congressman Bernie Sanders the at-large
independent from Vermont thank you very
much coming up in just a moment we'll be
talking with David Kessler of the Food
and Drug Administration and later we'll
turn our attention to health care we've
been showing you the proceedings in the
US House and also by the Ways and Means
Committee with Chairman Dan Rostenkowski
members are conducting a line-by-line
review of the measure what's known as a
markup session our live coverage of that
is expected to get underway at ten
o'clock this morning seven o'clock
pacific time the house will then convene
at ten thirty eastern 730 pacific time
for morning hour during that time
members will be able to speak on any
topic for up to five minutes after that
lawmakers are expected to continue
debate among the issues the Defense
Department authorization bill for fiscal
year 1995 that's at the US House which
will convene later this morning here on
c-span as most of the headlines in the
morning papers continue to show you the
nation is mourning the loss of Jackie
Kennedy Onassis yesterday burial
services were held here in Washington
across the river actually at Arlington
National Cemetery in Virginia and among
those who spoke